la commémoration pour le 66e
anniversaire de l'appel du général de
gaulle prononcé le 10 juin 1940 a eu
lieu ce samedi de nombreuses communes
ont organisé une cérémonie à cette
occasion et guyancourt ce sont des élus
des membres d'associations des anciens
combattants mais aussi des habitants qui
se sont rassemblées devant le monument
aux morts de la ville une classe de cp
de l'école jean mermoz était aussi
présente les élèves ont chanté à cette
occasion le chant des partisans
cette cérémonie commémorative faisait
également écho au drame terroriste 2
magnanville dans lequel deux
fonctionnaires de police ont perdu la
vie mais également aux attentats
terroristes survenus en novembre 2015 à
paris écouter gilles lebreton adjoint au
maire de la citoyenneté il était au
micro de manip ok c'est effectivement
important qui est des commémorations qui
est des rassemblements de personnel je
pense que
une minute de silence en hommage à ce
qui a pu se passer est important
aujourd'hui on est c'est bien de que
chacun se retrouve dans cette minute de
silence et repenser à ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a pu vivre à l'époque si les s'il
est encore là mais aussi sur les
événements récents de cette semaine et
les autres passé il ya quelques mois